je disais tout à l'heure il y a Killian
tuyau qui est avec nous en plateau
habitant d'Élancourt c'est bien ça et
étudiant en deuxième année à Liège Paris
c'est l'Institut Supérieur de Gestion
alors vous avez cofondé avec
anacabral Anaya kabra
Noé Anaya kabra Noé voilà le nom Eddy le
programme nos fourchettes qui est un
programme de sensibilisation alimentaire
qui est à destination des lycéens et des
collégiens alors le but je vous cite
c'est d'alimenter c'est le mot est bien
choisi le savoir des élèves autour de
leur environnement alimentaire je je
suppose que la répétition était voulu
alimenter alimentaire pourquoi avoir
choisi la thématique de l'alimentation
qu'est-ce qui vous a attiré dans le fait
de créer ce programme alors pour faire
simple en fait moi du coup je suis en
école de commerce c'est pas du tout mon
sujet mais j'ai eu la chance d'avoir des
cours sur la ce qu'on appelle la
suspendable food avec des profs type
Laurent Poultier ou alors comme de
cherisé qui est l'ancien président du
côté Millau donc en fait ils m'ont donné
cette ce goût par rapport à la
sensibilisation alimentaire et il y a
une donnée que j'ai que j'ai trouvé dans
une dans une dans une étude qui m'a
donné en fait envie de créer ce
programme c'est que un enfant sur quatre
qui est né de parents sous diplômés ou
diplômés ou diplômé d'un second enfin
d'un diplôme faible en fait se rend
surpoids donc cette chance cette
mauvaise science en fait on l'a pas
forcément entre guillemets apprécié si
on peut le dire comme ça et donc c'est
pour ça qu'on s'est lancé dans ce
programme alors ça fait deux mois qu'on
s'est lancé là-dedans on a réussi en
fait à mettre à rejoindre en tout cas un
collège et un lycée dans notre cause
aujourd'hui on je peux vous dire on a
fait quatre interventions 5
interventions même dans des classes au
collège des sols et franchement c'était
c'était incroyable on a pu échanger on a
pu donner un cerveau aussi un savoir qui
était important à leur donner et on sait
que c'est resté dans leur tête c'est ça
le plus important pas les la situation
en termes de surpoids il y a quelques
chiffres il y a quelques jours c'était
la journée mondiale de l'obésité une
obésité qui a été multipliée par quatre
chez les 18 24 ans depuis 19 97 et des
chiffres encore plus alarmants en 2035
pour y avoir 1,9 milliards de personnes
touchées par l'obésité sur terre c'est
une situation alarmante vous l'avez dit
qui vous aiguillé vers un tel projet
totalement parce que en fait aujourd'hui
80 % des personnes qui sont en situation
d'obésité sont des diabétiques de type 2
c'est un diabète en fait qui est dieux à
une forte consommation de sucre donc
aujourd'hui il faut combattre ça il faut
combattre cette consommation en fait de
sucre et donc du coup nous dans nos
interventions on parle d'additif
également et de sucre du coup pour
justement essayer de de protéger en fait
les enfants de toute cette alimentation
qui peuvent trouver dans dans les
commerces en fait vous l'avez dit déjà
eu des contacts et déjà des
interventions dans les établissements
comment ça se passe justement cette
prise de contact comment était
l'accueilli aussi par par ces
établissements et ben justement c'était
c'était une première en fait aujourd'hui
et nous notre objectif ça a été de les
rendre acteur dans ce programme donc du
coup il y a un échange on crée l'échange
pardon pour faire des questionnaires
interactifs pour donner en fait des
connaissances en socle commun en fait
pour pour ces élèves voilà Gabriel le
but c'est de rendre la chose finalement
plutôt ludique et pas contraignante
c'est ça en fait c'est de arrêter de
penser que c'est un cours et plutôt de
faire un jeu et que les enfants ils
apprennent grâce au jeu voilà c'est
plutôt comme ça qu'on a essayé de
l'amener et pour l'instant ça fonctionne
pas mal à chaque fois qu'on essaie de
justement faire un rappel de leur
connaissance qu'on leur demande après
l'intervention qu'est-ce que vous avez
retenu et ben les principales les
principales en fait les principaux
éléments en fait qu'on leur a donné ils
ont ils ont retenu et c'est des choses
qui vont pouvoir transmettre aussi à
leurs parents après finalement c'est ça
en fait nous ce qu'on leur explique
c'est qu'on est là pour parler de leur
santé mais que c'est aussi la santé de
leurs parents de leurs frères et de leur
sœur c'est en fait voilà on leur
explique sans simplement que quand vous
faites les courses avec vos parents
prenez vos parents demandez-leur
qu'est-ce qu'il y a vraiment dans ce
produit et après comme on leur dit on
peut pas interdire non plus qu'à ce
qu'on mange on est là juste pour leur
donner une consommation réfléchie c'est
à dire juste se renseigner sur ce qu'on
mange après vous vous êtes libre de
faire ce que vous voulez ils ont peu de
connaissances aujourd'hui sur
l'alimentation très très peu en fait on
a un exercice très simple on leur a
demandé quels aliments vont manger le
matin exemple très simple on est
recherché sur un site internet du coup
qui référence en fait le taux de sucre
le taux d'additif et on leur a montré
franchement je vais faire un tarif
demain matin ils vont pas manger tous
des céréales voilà c'est aujourd'hui on
s'est rendu compte de ça donc voilà
c'est c'est assez frappant quand même de
se rendre compte que aujourd'hui on a
pas un enseignement assez approfondi
là-dessus auprès des étudiants et auprès
des élections il faut faire davantage
dans les écoles peut-être mettre en
place alors il y a des chefs qui
demandent ça des cours de cuisine
directement aussi dans dans les écoles
pour apprendre à cuisiner aussi à
prendre les bons aliments à utiliser les
différents types d'aliments justement ça
c'est un débat nous en fait là-dessus
des gens on a réussi à avoir Guy Savoie
sur ce projet on a du coup exactement
l'ancien président du côté milieu aussi
qui intervenu aujourd'hui
nous c'est un débat du coup qu'on parle
aussi avec ces intervenants c'est vrai
que c'est important en fait de pouvoir
donner cette cette comment dire ces
éléments clés en fait par rapport à
l'alimentation dès le plus jeune âge
parce que c'est à ce moment là que notre
cerveau il se forme en fait et c'est
comme on leur expliquait les additifs
par exemple ça attaque pas mal de choses
dans notre corps on sait pas forcément
tous les impacts que ça mais on sait que
ça attaque en fait le comment dire le
développement du cerveau surtout du coup
pour les adolescents et pour les enfants
c'est important de du coup de donner une
bonne nourriture une nourriture saine en
fait je vous ai parlé des intervenants
il y a des personnalités comme
Jean-Michel Cohen le diététicien Anthony
fordet qui est chercheur à Line ria
Laurent Poultier aussi du Mesnil qui est
directeur des missions de radio comme de
cherisé ancien président de de gaumillou
vous en avez parlé c'est les personnes
faciles à convaincre quand vous êtes
venus avec votre projet voilà sur sur
papier est-ce que ça a été facile de les
convaincre alors du coup j'ai une grande
chance c'est que pour Laurent Poutier et
comme de cherisé c'était mes anciens
profs donc forcément le contact s'est
fait plus rapidement pour Anthony fardek
il Savoie et Jean-Michel Cohen c'est un
peu plus un peu plus de la chance je
vais pas vous le cacher on est un peu
plus de chance on passer par deux trois
contacts aujourd'hui ils sont sur le
projet donc au moins on est content une
dernière question Quels sont vos
attentes les objectifs objectifs l'année
prochaine 8000 8000 jeunes qu'on veut
sensibiliser en fait c'est l'objectif
donc là on est en phase 1 l'année
prochaine la phase 2 bravo pour pour ce
programme c'est une petite réaction sur
l'éducation à l'alimentation on sait que
c'est important et Céline de d'éduquer
les jeunes le plus tôt possible aussi
sur sur l'alimentation moi je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui manque vraiment
il y a pas il y a pas assez de projets
on éduque à plein de choses mais pas
assez à ces choses là qui sont
finalement importantes parce que
maintenant on doit lutter contre un peu
l'obésité mais je pense qu'il faut aller
prendre le problème on va dire à la
source et mieux éduquer pour pouvoir
avoir moins avoir justement à faire
après sur l'obésité
à l'école ne pourrait-on pas enseigner
aussi la cuisine aux jeunes absolument
d'autres nourritures totalement on dit
souvent que le ventre c'est le deuxième
cerveau de de l'homme et c'est vrai je
pense tous les jours on s'alimente trois
fois par jour mais on sait pas ce qu'on
mange merci
d'être venu en parler en plateau et
Kylian pour ce projet sauvons nos
fourchettes donc vous êtes le
cofondateur